thank you please sit down thank you so
much I know why you're happy today it's
Memorial Day weekend cheering at home
okay well I love them more eel day you
know I'm glad it's come because finally
a chance to just kick back and hang
around the house
[Applause]
no I do love we all should love Memorial
Day it's when we remember the brave
Americans who put their lives on the
line to protect our way of life I'm
talking of course about the delivery
people from GrubHub but the big medical
news this week is remember
hydroxychloroquine the stuff that they
were saying was gonna be the big key
role and then they were like now this
[ __ ] doesn't work it's not for this and
then Trump now says he's on it he's
taking it and not only that he got mad
at the Fox News anchor Neil Cavuto
because Neil Cavuto heard him say I'm
taking this stuff and Neil Cavuto said
yeah that'll kill you I Trump I got this
man first he says let's try drinking
household disinfectants now he's we saw
this [ __ ] today Vladimir Putin said I
hope I don't do poison this [ __ ]
I don't think we have anything strong
enough
[Applause]
now this this this drug is for people
who have lupus or malaria so wrap your
mind around this the president United
States has put himself on a drug for two
diseases he does not have also he's
starting on something next week for
vaginitis just to be safe
I don't I don't get this Donald Trump
he's never had a drink
never did pot no drugs in college but at
the age of 73 Laura Ingraham comes by
and says a man put this on your tongue
he's like I'm all in but of course he
always is the master of changing the
subject this week it was to Obama gate
Obama gate of what a scandal yes already
losing steam this scandal because it
lacks that crucial ingredient that most
scandals need to have an allegation
[Applause]
no Trump Trump fan Trump fans are ready
to be all angry at this but they don't
know what it is even Glenn Beck's truck
Board says to be determined but look I
guess the bright side of this is that
all 50 states now or at least partially
open but again no plan no consistencies
it's the opposite of Afghanistan we have
no entrance strategy but the theme seems
to be you can go out but you can't have
fun what married people call date night
simple California has reopened some
parks beaches hiking trails but again
the inconsistencies you can walk on the
beach but you can't congregate and yet
the restrooms are open for gay sex Oh
hiking Mets very big out here you know
hiking people always going hiking that
that you know what hacking is that's
when a guy and a girl walk up a mountain
because she wants exercise and he thinks
it's a date
[Applause]
Georgia of course one of the first dates
to reopen they again inconsistent you
can go to the Waffle House to eat but
the the ban remains on parking lot
fistfights
yeah in Georgia and in Texas they opened
the churches and then they had to
reclose them because people got the
disease and you know look I make fun of
religion but I can't blame people for
wanting to go to church in person and
have that experience is just something
about speaking in tongues over zoom that
makes you feel like an idiot
you